hey I was going friends my name is
PewDiePie what please what do you want
Stuckey cutie pie I'm doing my intro
this is my show
how's it going please shut the [ __ ] up
no no it's super cool
ok no I'm not turning around there's
only two things in the world
that would make me turn around and look
what's behind me number one Donald
Trump's penis number two a [ __ ] toad
well well well
Felix look what we have here today is
your lucky day a toad
you got a toad
you got a toad oh that's amazing
thank you fake beauty pot come here wait
wait fake Peter pie can you could you
film this for me I want to interact with
the toad
thank you fake feelings forgive you know
how heartbroken I was when instantly
left me a toad thank you now I'm not
[ __ ] touching that [ __ ] though touch
it you [ __ ]
now you touch it no no no no no no no
okay fine I'll play with sleepy all
right guys we bought a toad I don't know
why I think this is a terrible idea but
he's in here his name is slippy I've
never touched him before I want to be
gentle
and make sure sleepy is either easy
there
hey okay all right
I'm terrified of this tone I'm legit
scared of even looking at it because you
don't know it looks calm right now all
right
it could sleep we could attack at any
moment why am I such a [ __ ] [ __ ] he
looks calm but Eagles oh you see that he
moves he's a little scared don't go he
will attack he looks like the big mean
toad from the river jeez I'm so [ __ ]
scared I'm such a [ __ ] Jesus hey sleepy
how you doing sleeping let me just say
hello to you sleeping
hey how you doing sleepy he's smelling
me look at his nose he's sleepy he feels
like sandpaper all day oh my god
I'm what I'm not scared
okay I'm not scared you think I'm scared
look look I'm not scared at all Oh God
hey sleepy would you mind if I
he's nice
hey it's pretty chill actually hey don't
jump in sleep you don't killing yourself
look at him
hey sleepy okay he's gone
good boy good boy he's cool I never hold
one before it so this is a cane toad
they can get huge and they live for like
10 to 15 years oh hey it's like holding
a cheeseburger it's really it's really
weird so they do bite they have a really
strong jaw so I want to be careful but
he's pretty chill I like him
is this cool how you doing - sleepy can
I face my fear today guys so we're gonna
give sleepy a voice he's really cool why
did you get tired
cuz I'm scared of them I figured like an
animal that I don't like would be the
perfect pet for the PewDiePie channel
he's really cool I really like him
alright well sleep is now a member of
the family Ainsley
rest his soul I hope he doesn't get too
big let's show the show some footage of
like how big they can get also if you
lick sleeping I have to wash my hands
now because he's venomous so if you
licks if you I wanna you know get that
put a PI on just lick just lick him
loosen really yeah you could be like you
could do you guys like the name sleepy
so I thought sleepy would just be like
the coolest most original idea for frog
no one else has ever named their their
frog sleepy so I just thought it would
be like a really cool original idea what
do you have a skull in that Kesley PE is
a warlock we'll get a better house for
him
and he'll get more accustomed and sleepy
will hopefully live a long happy life
together with Felix and Friends alright
well thanks for watching leave a like
for all the toads in the world now I
will brofist
[Music]